bien
nous allons reprendre le fil de notre
mission
nous poursuivons donc les travaux de
notre mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant en carburant synthétique
durable hydrogène vert par une audition
conjointe de la Commission de régulation
d'énergie de RTE et de enedis
je salue ici monsieur Yvan Faucheux
commissaire membre du collège de la
Commission de régulation d'énergie
monsieur Jean-Philippe Bonnet directeur
adjoint du pôle stratégie prospective et
évaluation de RTE qui est accompagné de
Monsieur Philippe pilves directeur des
relations institutionnelles de RTA et
Monsieur Dominique Lagarde directeur de
la stratégie d'enedis je rappelle que
cette réunion elle est captée et
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra ensuite
être consultée en vidéo à la demande
messieurs notre mission d'information
comprend des membres
issus des différentes commissions du
Sénat et qui représente l'ensemble des
groupes politiques de notre assemblée le
développement des filières de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert
sera l'un des éléments importants de la
décarbonation des transports et donc
l'une des voies pour atteindre les
objectifs ambitieux que c'est assigner
l'Union européenne au travers du pacte
vert et du paquet ajustement à
l'objectif 55 or l'un des enjeux très
net qui ressort de nos précédentes
auditions c'est la question de la
capacité de notre pays à produire
suffisamment d'électricité pour
accompagner la production nationale
d'hydrogène ou de carburant de synthèse
mais aussi à lever certains freins au
raccordement de grands projets
industriels au réseau électrique nous
avons également été alertés à plusieurs
reprises dans cette perspective sur la
question des conflits d'usage et sur la
répartie la répartition des différents
vecteurs énergétiques entre les secteurs
économiques notamment entre la décar de
l'industrie et la décarbonation des
transports il est important donc d'avoir
votre vision de ces enjeux notre
rapporteur monsieur Vincent Kapo canelas
qui est à l'origine de notre mission que
je tiens à vous présenter et à vous
faire accepter ces excuses car il était
appelé en urgence sur ses fonctions
d'élus locales vous a adressé un
questionnaire qui peut servir guide mais
après tout vous intervenez comme vous
souhaitez faire votre induction à votre
introduction
j'essayerai mais je serais pas tout seul
de vous poser des questions en l'absence
du rapporteur qui est très fort pour
relancer d'ailleurs avec mes collègues
et puis bien évidemment sur les
questions qui vous ont été
transmises par Vincent capo canelas vous
pourrez nous les transmettre
ultérieurement par écrit et c'est avec
plaisir qu'on en prendra connaissance je
propose de céder en premier lieu la
parole à Monsieur Yvan Faucheux
commissaire membre de la Commission de
la Commission de régulation d'énergie
monsieur je vous cède la parole
monsieur le Président je la prends avec
grand plaisir et vous remercie pour
cette audition
alors la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie et la première question c'est
que fait donc la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie dans l'hydrogène
et dans les biocarbures de synthèse nous
avons la commission régulation de
l'énergie un exercice qui s'appelle un
exercice de prospective alors qu'il
n'est pas strictement attaché aux
fonctions de régulateur en régulateur et
pour le dire un peu brutalement c'est
celui qui fait appliquer les règles
d'une jeu une fois qu'elles sont
définies français de constater que dans
le domaine de l'hydrogène et des
biocarbures de synthèse elles sont pas
encore totalement définies ce qui nous
empêche pas d'essayer d'anticiper un
petit peu quelles sont les principaux
enjeux qui vont émerger de secteurs et
leur impact potentiel sur sur la
régulation donc au sein du comité de
prospective on a deux on a eu deux
rapports récents
alors je dirais ça le premier date de
2021 il était sur le vecteur hydrogène
donc ça tombe plutôt bien et le deuxième
est tout récent puisqu'il date de
d'avril 2023 il était plutôt que sur la
question de la ressource biomasse
qui est effectivement une des questions
que vous avez soulevé il y aura-t-il
suffisamment de biomasse pour tout le
monde
si je dois résumer à très grand trait
les deux rapports je vais commencer par
le rapport sur l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène pour la décarbonation de
l'industrie
et notamment quand la molécule hydrogène
est utilisée comme molécule chimique de
base ne connaît pas beaucoup
d'alternatives c'est à dire que si on
met de côté notamment dans l'acide
urgies des des
technologies autres la molécule
hydrogène si elle n'est pas décarbonée
on ne sait plus comment faire tourner un
certain nombre de process industriels
donc on a classé les usages de
l'hydrogène en se disant est-ce qu'il y
avait notamment des alternatives des
carbonées plus abordables ou plus ou
moins abordables c'est-à-dire qu'il y
avait une concurrence en termes de
décarbonation pour un certain nombre de
d'activités industrielles enfin pour la
plus le plus grand nombre des activités
industrielles
l'hydrogène des carbonée et je
reviendrai un petit peu sur le sujet
parce que vous avez utilisé le mot vert
qui ne veut pas dire décarbonée et comme
vous le savez je crois qu'il doit y
avoir à peu près une quinzaine de
couleurs de l'hydrogène aujourd'hui
l'hydrogène décarbonée et une solution
qui ne serait trouver d'alternative
aujourd'hui viable au moins
économiquement viable technologiquement
prouvé ou économiquement viable ce qui
fait quand même que le coût de la tonne
de CO2 éviter pour avoir de l'hydrogène
des carbonées et dans les conditions des
prix de l'énergie des prix de
l'électricité en 2021 il fallait un coup
de la tonne de CO2 éviter entre 100 et
150 euros par tonne pour arriver à
justifier l'investissement dans la
décarbonation de ces process industriels
dans les transports la question est plus
complexe de par l'existence d'un certain
nombre d'alternatives décarbonés
notamment le véhicule électrique pour le
véhicule particulier
pour le train l'électrification des
lignes ou la batterie électrochimique et
pour le transport lourd les bus et les
véhicules utilitaires la batterie
électrochimique le biogenv etc etc ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui dans ce secteur
là des transports la vision était que
l'hydrogène est en concurrence avec un
certain nombre d'autres vecteurs
énergétiques des carbonés et je cite
notamment le biogenv puisque le biogaz
ne sert pas uniquement à chauffer mais
il peut aussi servir à être un carburant
en substitution de de carburant standard
là l'affaire ce corps si vous permettez
à l'expression puisque on monte à des
coûts de la tonne de CO2 éviter qui sont
plutôt de l'ordre de 400 à 450 euros le
meilleur la tonne de CO2 Vitt pour
arriver à avoir des des modèles
économiques y compris dans les dans les
dans les transports bus poids lourds
véhicules utilitaires ce qui veut dire
que l'hydrogène dans ce secteur-là et
c'est un secteur de qui consomme
énormément de de
ressources puisque fondamentalement
quand même les hydrocarbures utilisés
dans le domaine des véhicules lour DS et
25% des du pétrole qui est utilisé pour
les pour le carburant c'est très peu de
véhicules enfin c'est très peu de
véhicule pour ceux qui font l'autoroute
A6 le dimanche soir parfois on peut
trouver que c'est beaucoup de véhicules
néanmoins c'est très peu de véhicules
mais c'est une grosse consommation et
donc là dessus l'hydrogène ne se
positionnera que en concurrence et un
avantage compétitif par rapport à
d'autres solutions décarbonées
et enfin on a regardé également
l'hydrogène pour un certain nombre de
d'applications pour pouvoir stocker de
l'électricité quand l'électricité est
pas cher déstocker donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle le power to gas to power ou le
power to gaz et là au cas d'espèces de
la France
il est très difficile de trouver un
modèle économique c'est-à-dire les seuls
modèles économiques sont dans des
secteurs où il y a très peu
d'alternatives typiquement en Guyane
récemment un projet solaire plus
stockage électrochimique plus hydrogène
dans une zone totalement
quasiment totalement non interconnecté a
du sens le stockage électrochimique
permettant de faire la variation jour
nuit voire hebdomadaires et l'hydrogène
permettant d'absorber les variations sur
les sur les plus longues durées
donc ça c'est le premier rapport le
deuxième rapport qui a été fait était
sur la ressource biomasse il est
beaucoup alors il est beaucoup plus si
vous le lisez vous allez être très
frustré parce que en fait il n'affecte
pas la ressource biomasse tout ce qu'il
constate c'est que il y a dans la
ressource biomasse aujourd'hui trois
grands vecteurs d'applications
il y a évidemment le vecteur
agroalimentaire qui est un gros
consommateur de biomasse il y a
également le vecteur du du bois utilisé
pour faire de la construction ou pour
faire des tables par exemple et puis il
y a le vecteur énergétique et il y a
deux façons de regarder la biomasse la
première façon de regarder la biomasse
c'est sa capacité à se renouveler c'est
à dire ce qui a sa capacité à s'insérer
dans un écosystème vivant où il faut
laisser suffisamment de biomasse
retourner à la terre en capter ce qu'il
faut mais pas trop et s'adapter à un
changement climatique qui aujourd'hui va
conduire certaines espèces à la
fortement dépérir notamment sur la
ressource bois
et par ailleurs la biomasse est un puits
carbone qui s'est effondré puisque on
est passé de mémoire de 50 millions de
tonnes par an depuis carbone à quelques
vins et des poussières de captation par
la par les par la forêt
et donc la question de savoir si en
fonction du fait que la biomasse est une
biomasse à cycle courte ou acycle longue
cycle long c'est la forêt cycle court
c'est plutôt la l'agriculture puis vous
avez des cycles intermédiaires et
qu'elle est utilisée elle-même dans des
applications qui sont à cycles longs à
cycle court par rapport à l'enjeu des
carbonation et à la nécessité de freiner
très rapidement le stock de CO2
anthropique dans l'atmosphère on n'a pas
du tout la même façon de voir
l'utilisation de la biomasse
donc ça c'était un peu les les grands
sujets
je vais également insister sur un
élément qu'on a sur lequel on pour le
coup la Creuse c'est plus ou moins
prononcé alors la Creuse se prononce
jamais de façon totalement assertive
elle pousse toujours des questions
mais souvent quand on regarde derrière
la question on a la réponse
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de débats
aujourd'hui sur est-ce que l'hydrogène
doit être décarbonée ou est-ce qu'il
doit être vers c'est à dire produit avec
des sources renouvelables ou produits
avec des sources décarbonées nous notre
constat c'est que c'est un débat alors
certes très intéressant
néanmoins il y a beaucoup d'outils qui
permettent de pousser les énergies
renouvelables par ailleurs et que donc
utiliser un outil de soutien à
l'hydrogène
pour 8 pour comment dire pour soutenir
le déploiement d'une autre filière ne
s'impose pas économiquement c'est une
question qui qui est ouverte
après tout un bon outil public a
toujours du mal à gérer plusieurs
objectifs à la fois et là se dire
qu'avec le même outil de soutien à
l'hydrogène on peut avoir de la
décarbonation par la décernation de
soutien aux énergies renouvelables et de
l'hydrogène des carbonée il nous paraît
quand même plus sain d'avoir un outil de
soutien public à la décarbonation et
quand on regarde ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis avec l'Iran
réduction Act puisque le mot ira avait
une autre signification et quand même
quelques années
la table de réduction d'impôts qui est
liée à l'usage ou au projet d'hydrogène
et uniquement lié au contenu carbone de
cette hydrogène puisque je sais pas si
vous avez la table exactement en tête
mais en quotité comment taux il y a 5 ou
différents types d'hydrogène et ce qui
discrimine l'hydrogène c'est uniquement
son contenu carbone
donc on observe un que c'est un débat
qui est très européen et que par
ailleurs d'autres États vont sur des
outils beaucoup plus simple de soutien à
l'hydrogène des carbonée
je vais finir parce que sinon je vais
être trop long puis ça me permettra de
poser aussi un certain nombre de
questions
qu'on soit sur des carburants de
synthèse au sens biocarburant deuxième
génération ou de l'hydrogène des
carbonées on est sur un vecteur de
stockage tout à l'heure ce que j'ai
raconté sur l'existence de technologie
alternative comme vous avez pu le noter
et en mettant le biogène V à part
puisque lui
plus peut-être issu de la méta-nation de
la méthanisation qui sont deux de
technologie lors de l'État nation plus
qui est plus une technologie de stockage
encore que mais la méthanisation c'est
clairement une technologie qui utilise
la valeur énergétique de la plante ou de
déchets ou de STEP pour ensuite refaire
un autre vecteur énergétique quel CH4
grâce à l'aide des petites bactéries
qu'on trouve soit dans le système
digestif de lavage soit dans les fosse
septiques mais donc ça veut dire que
c'est quand même une technologie qui
date
très très longtemps
quand on regarde les carburants de
synthèse et
l'hydrogène des carbonées ce sont
effectivement deux vecteurs de stockage
ces vecteurs de stockage nécessitent
d'avoir accès à une énergie décarbonée
aujourd'hui des énergies décarbonées
à part des énergies électriques il
existe relativement peu de vecteurs
décarbonés autre que les énergies
électriques et quand elles existent leur
utilisation dans un système électrique
n'est pas forcément le système le plus
efficace c'est à dire que quand on
dispose de biogaz
est-il plus intelligent de le brûler
dans une chaudière qui permet de
chauffer ou faut-il l'envoyer dans une
centrale à gaz qui par ailleurs à 50% de
rendement donc quand on est face à une
rareté de la ressource et notamment de
la ressource énergétique l'enjeu du
rendement s'impose d'emblée
si on est face à des outils de stockage
mais il y a bien évidemment il faut
avoir de l'énergie des carbonées ce qui
nous renvoie un débat qui je pense ne
fait que commencer sur
la capacité à atteindre à les soyons
fous 700 à 750 térawatts mais je
laisserai immédiatement la parole à RTU
qui connaît les chiffres par cœur de
production d'électricité en France et
aussi les questions de raccordement
si on se dit l'industrie comme je l'ai
évoqué au début l'industrie est un
investissement sans regret pour la
production d'hydrogène des carbonée je
laisserai les transports un peu de côté
le débat est beaucoup plus compliqué
cette industrie se concentre dans
quelques bassins industriels
c'est-à-dire que 50 % des plus gros
sites industriels fait grosso modo 50 %
des émissions
de CO2 et par ailleurs se concentre dans
une dizaine de bassins alors parfois 11
parfois 9 ça dépend du ça dépend du ça
dépend des jours
effectivement il y a un enjeu qui est
d'apporter énormément d'électricité
sur quelques bassins industriels ce qui
est surtout un enjeu pour RTI puisque ce
sont souvent des lignes de très haute
tension
ça c'est la première partie des gros
industriels et par ailleurs il y a un
tissu industriel qui est lui beaucoup
plus diffus et qui peut avoir besoin
d'hydrogène des carbonée et là dessus je
pense qu'on aura un déploiement ou une
des questions en deux étapes une
question d'abord pour un réseau de
transport c'est à dire que la première
difficulté va se trouver par rapport au
réseau de transport gérer la
décarbonation de l'hydrogène sur un
certain nombre de bassins industriels
mais qui seront d'abord sur des lignes
de transport et ensuite comment découler
pour le réseau de distribution
voilà c'était l'objet de l'introduction
j'espère ne pas vous avoir saoulé
mais en tout cas effectivement que ce
soit sous l'angle production
distribution transport
et j'allais rajouter impact
environnemental de tout ceci puisqu'une
de transport n'est pas sans impact
environnemental
effectivement nous sommes face à un
objet multifacettes qui n'est pas tout à
fait facile à appréhender
merci alors ni sous les ni endormi
de questions est-ce que vous pouvez
parler de l'irra mais avec la nouvelle
appellation
pouvez-vous préciser votre analyse sur
sur concernant l'Iran américain et ça ça
simplicité et quelle conclusion
tirez-vous pour l'Europe et puis la
hausse actuelle des prix d'énergie
constitue-t-elle
un frein ou une opportunité pour le
développement de filière française dans
l'hydrogène vers les carburants
synthétiques durables et les
biocarburants et
le pourquoi
si ça constitue dans un sens ou dans un
autre merci
ok alors la première question est sur
l'IRA donc Lyra effectivement le je vous
ai dit une bêtise il y a que quatre
catégories puisque ça va de 0 à 0,45 et
ensuite de 5 à 4 kg de CO2 par kilo de
d'hydrogène des carbonée
c'est un choix qui a été fait par le
gouvernement américain d'utilisa plutôt
un outil fiscal il a un avantage ça
simplicité sa lisibilité et mon
commentaire était qu'il était basé sur
le contenu CO2 et pas sur d'autres
d'autres vertus de l'hydrogène donc ça
c'est fait partie de la simplicité en
revanche effectivement là je sors un peu
du rôle de la creux il a un désavantage
c'est que comme tout outil fiscal sont
sa pilotabilité en cas de bulle et pas
tout à fait évidente alors je disais que
je sors un peu du rôle de la creux mais
pas tant que ça il y a pas longtemps
nous avons eu à instruire les clauses de
sauvegarde dans la bulle PV vous savez
les tarifs
2006-2010 qui avait un moment explosé
c'est à dire qu'un outil public qui a un
moment n'a pas un garde-fou budgétaire
quelque part autant les États-Unis
ou une facilité à utiliser des outils
budgétaires qui n'ont pas forcément des
garde-fous parce qu'ils ont par ailleurs
d'autres garde-fous et d'autres
modalités de financement de leur dette
autant pour l'Europe et notamment pour
la France la question de savoir si cet
outil
a une pilotabilité budgétaire est
importante et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
issus des ordonnances les outils que met
en place la France sont plutôt des
outils à forte pilotabilité budgétaire
mon point étant pas forcément de se
prononcer sur la pilotabilité budgétaire
ou pas mon point était plutôt de dire
que quand on regarde ce que font les
États-Unis et indépendamment de ce point
de pilotabilité budgétaire le critère de
base c'est le contenu CO2 de l'hydrogène
et pas forcément d'autres vertus
embarquées de l'hydrogène
alors ça c'était la première question et
je vais m'excuser la deuxième question
qui m'est passé
votre deuxième question
la hausse des prix voilà ça y est je
alors
la hausse du prix de l'énergie alors
on avait dans le cas du du comité de
prospective regardez essayer de faire un
petit peu des abaques en fonction de
l'augmentation du prix de l'électricité
quel impact cela pouvait avoir sur le
coût de l'hydrogène des carbonée
l'hydrogène des carbonées ayant
un rendement qui n'est pas exceptionnel
tout hausse du prix de l'électricité et
notamment quand on est en concurrence
avec des solutions plutôt électriques
donc stockage électrochimique
évidemment ne sont pas bonnes pour elles
l'accès pour l'hydrogène décarbonée à
une électricité décarbonée
pas trop cher je dis pas trop cher c'est
à dire plutôt dans les prix de marché
c'est à dire qu'il lui permet de se
comparer à ses concurrents mais surtout
qu'ils soient pas source qui soit pas
soumis à une très forte volatilité et
d'autant plus important pour l'hydrogène
qui a besoin d'un fonctionnement
relativement stable et relativement en
base par rapport à ces alternatives
électriques notamment stockage qui lui
est beaucoup plus
résilient à des Stop and Go ou à des
capacités à s'adapter ou à capter les
les opportunités de prix bas de
l'énergie ou de prix élevé de
l'électricité
donc nous notre analyse
c'est que les difficiles pour
l'hydrogène des carbonée de vivre dans
un monde dans lequel il accès à
l'électricité des carbonées soit
significativement supérieur à 60 euros
le mégawattheure compte tenu des
perspectives technologiques et contenues
des perspectives de rendement des
électrolyseurs et qu'en tout cas la
volatilité pour le modèle économique de
la production d'hydrogène des carbonées
est un élément qui
est de première c'est à dire que si on
vit dans un monde dans lequel le chiffre
que je vous annoncé est un chiffre qui
est à peu près correct
dans ce cas là il faut que la volatilité
reste extrêmement mesurée pour s'adapter
au fait que l'électricité que
l'hydrogène des carbonée l'électrolyseur
étant quand même un gros CAPEX amortir
et que donc l'utilisation annuelle de
l'électrolyseur est un facteur important
du coup
et que si l'utiliser entre 8000 et 7000
heures par an c'est pas très grave mais
si on descend à des taux d'utilisation
de l'ordre de 2000 à 2500 heures par an
c'est à dire brancher directement sur un
champ photovoltaïque de bonne qualité
avec un bon ensoleillement le CAPEX
l'amortissement du CAPEX de
l'électrolyseur prend le pas sur le coup
l'électricité et rend l'hydrogène des
carbonée extrêmement peu abordable enfin
en tout cas on est plus dans les ordres
de grandeur que je vous avais cité les
100 euros par tonne
c'est dans l'hypothèse d'un
électrolyseur qui fonctionne 6000 heures
par an
et on avait pris à l'époque 45 euros par
méga water ce qui prouve que il y a des
fois où la prospective est un exercice
d'une très grande difficulté
merci je vois que Gérard on va faire
comme ça non tu bon alors je vais
maintenant passer la parole à Monsieur
Jean-Philippe bonnet je reprécise
directement adjoint du pôle stratégie
perspective et évaluation de RTA
monsieur bonnet vous avez je vous aide
la parole pour une quinzaine de minutes
voire plus
merci je vais essayer d'être le plus
synthétique possible
donc vous connaissez RTE plusieurs
plusieurs rôles qui sont exercés un rôle
de gestionnaire de d'une infrastructure
vitale et qui est concerné par le
transport d'électricité pour l'hydrogène
j'y reviendrai un rôle d'équilibre du
système électrique en temps réel à moyen
terme voire à long terme et puis une
activité de prospective aussi en lien
avec ce rôle d'équilibrage du système
électrique
pour essayer de de cerner ce que sera
notre futur énergétique futur le plus
décarboné possible et avec une des
questions qui se pose qu'à émerger sur
la scène énergétique depuis quelques
années qui est celle de la place de
l'hydrogène
donc l'hydrogène peut peut être
d'évoluer à de très nombreux rôles qui
ont été évoqués par Monsieur Faucheux
ils n'y reviendrai pas mais ils ont un
point commun c'est que pour produire
l'hydrogène des carbonée aujourd'hui
tout le monde mise beaucoup sur
l'électricité l'électrolyse
et donc il va y avoir besoin de produire
cette électricité et de la cheminée vers
les électrolyseurs
une des questions c'est combien
d'électricité tout ça va représenter
seule chose qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
c'est que il est très difficile de de
bâtir sur des chiffres solides fiables
parce qu'on est vraiment à un point de
d'inflexion de démarrage d'une filière
la rapidité de ce décollage jusqu'où
tout ça va va s'envoler avant peut-être
de se stabiliser sont des questions
encore très ouvertes
a produit
deux rapports qui se sont intéressés à
l'hydrogène principalement un rapport en
2019 qui était centré sur l'hydrogène
le rapport de 2021 sur les futurs
énergétiques qui embrassait très
largement la question de la
décarbonation du système énergétique
mais qui laissait aussi une belle place
aux questions autour de l'hydrogène et
puis en ce moment nous avons des travaux
sur le bilan prévisionnel de l'offre et
de la demande d'électricité à l'horizon
2030 2035 ou les questions autour
d'hydrogène sont aussi assez premium
si je reviens rapidement sur sur la
vision qu'on a pu avoir par le passé
sur notre rapport 2019 et même sur les
sur les futurs énergétiques de 2021 nous
étions dans un dans un discours qui
visait déjà battre en brèche l'idée que
l'hydrogène aurait d'abord pour rôle de
stocker l'électricité excédentaire pour
la restituer au moment où on en avait
besoin en tout cas c'est un rôle qui à
court terme nous semblait
plutôt plutôt secondaire
et ce que nous disions dans le rapport
2019 c'est que la priorité c'était
d'abord d'utiliser l'hydrogène pour
remplacer l'hydrogène actuellement
utilisée dans l'industrie et puis
éventuellement jouer un rôle aussi dans
la décarbonation de la mobilité lourde
ce discours là il a été réaffirmé en
2021 avec ces deux ces deux notions et
on a des scénarios qui qui fluctuent
avec des visions à l'horizon 2050 de 60
térawattheure de d'électricité pour
l'hydrogène dans les hypothèses basses
avec la un rôle surtout centré sur
l'industrie existante
assez peu sur la mobilité et sur le sur
le stockage et ça pouvait monter jusqu'à
150 terawattheure dans le scénario qu'on
a payé hydrogène plus où là
l'utilisation d'hydrogène pour la
mobilité devenez même prépondérant sur
l'utilisation dans des industries
historiques
pétrochimie ou sidérurgie
donc une fourchette quand même très
large et une fourchette qui reste aussi
très très large à l'horizon 2030 2035
puisque dans les travaux sur le bilan
prévisionnel
on est sur un éventail à l'horizon 2030
2035 qui est
entre
11 et 34 terwattheure vous voyez de 1 à
3 à l'horizon 2030 et entre 16 et 68h le
11835 enfin je vous transmettrai ces
chiffres là retenez simplement que c'est
à la fois beaucoup d'électricité ça
pourrait représenter 10 15% de la
consommation d'électricité française
mais avec des très fortes d'incertitudes
vues d'aujourd'hui
ensuite on pourrait dire bon mais si on
veut arriver dès 2030 et 2035 à ces
niveaux là ça doit se voir il devrait y
avoir des projets lancés il doit y avoir
des demandes de raccordement réseau et
effectivement c'est le cas donc deuxième
casquette de RTE notre casquette de
gestion d'infrastructures nous avons
reçu au cours des 18 derniers mois deux
dernières années mais ça c'est vraiment
emballé dans l'année qui vient de
s'écouler énormément de demandes de
raccordement aux réseaux de transport à
haute-têtrée haute tension pour des
électrolyseurs de fortes puissances sur
des puissances de 150 200 600 700
mégawatts sont des puissances pour
lesquelles aujourd'hui il n'existe pas
d'électrolyseur de ce niveau là dans le
monde c'est ce sont des choses qui alors
l'électrolyse est modulable donc il
existe des électroviseurs de plus
petites puissances et il suffit de les
aligner pour arriver à des puissances
très importantes mais aujourd'hui ça
n'existe pas quand on fait le cumul de
toutes les demandes que nous avons
reçues on arrive à 12 GW de puissance
on arrive à 12 gigawatts de puissance
12 gigawatts on n'est pas loin de la
puissance totale appelée par l'industrie
en France on est sur une douzaine de
réacteurs nucléaires sur des chiffres
quand même très importants le pour
donner un ordre de comparaison la
stratégie française établie par le
gouvernement vise un objectif de 6,5
gigawatts à l'horizon 2030
donc les projets développés par des
opérateurs très divers vous avez des
opérateurs historiques qui qui ont des
filiales qui travaillent sur ces projets
d'hydrogène mais on a vu émerger aussi
des nouveaux acteurs
qui se sont lancés dans secteur là pour
développer des projets
donc
en résumé beaucoup de projets de grandes
incertitudes pour savoir à quel rythme
ces projets vont réellement émerger
parce qu'on a beaucoup de projets en
face de d'instruction de de démarrage
mais très peu de décisions réelles
d'investissement tous ces acteurs se
positionnent et c'est de capter le
foncier c'est de capter la capacité
disponible sur le réseau donc il y a un
jeu concurrentiel assez fort mais chacun
se regarde aussi pour savoir qui va
réellement démarrer le premier
donc beaucoup d'incertitudes sur
quand est-ce que ça va réellement
décoller jusqu'où ça va monter
la seule certitude qu'on a et c'est ce
qui évoqué monsieur Faucheux c'est c'est
où est-ce que ça va se passer d'abord ça
va se passer d'abord dans les grandes
zones industrielles et dans les grandes
zones industrielles au portuaires ou il
y a la conjonction aujourd'hui de
fonciers disponible
pour l'industrie dans cet angle de
d'infrastructures qui sont favorables et
puis de clients potentiels qui sont des
industries existantes souhaitant
recourir à l'hydrogène pour décarboner
leurs process
donc dans ce cadre là RTE a engagé
d'ores et déjà un certain nombre
d'investissements pour renforcer la
capacité d'alimentation d'électricité de
quatre premières grandes zones
industrielles qui sont la zone de
Dunkerque la zone du Havre pour Jérôme
dans la dans l'estuaire de la Seine la
zone de Fos-sur-Mer et la vallée de la
chimie au sud de Lyon
qui sont des zones où se concentrent
réellement les demandes de raccordement
de vos électrolyseurs et où ces demandes
en fait ce cumulent avec aussi des
projets de décarbonation direct de
l'industrie de passage des fours
électriques par exemple et à des
gigafactory l'actualité s'en fait l'écho
de production de batterie ou de
production de panneaux solaires qui
veulent aussi s'installer sur ces
grandes zones donc sont des secteurs ou
on n'a pas de doute sur le fait qu'il va
y avoir besoin d'électricité dans les
années à venir et RTE investit on a
lancé un programme de 1 milliard et demi
à deux milliards d'euros
d'investissement pour développer
progressivement la capacité d'acheminer
l'électricité vers ces zones
industrielles
donc ça pose des questions sur lequel on
pourra revenir effectivement de
simplification d'accélération
votre assemblée à voter un centre de
mesure dans la loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables qui nous seront
très utiles pour à la fois mutualiser le
coût de ces investissements entre
RTE et donc la collectivité mais aussi
de faire payer une partie aux
industriels qui vont bénéficier ça va
nous permettre d'accélérer un certain
nombre de procédures et ça doit nous
permettre aussi de rationaliser la
location de la capacité c'est-à-dire de
donner à l'état des leviers pour mettre
un peu d'ordre dans cette concurrence
effrénée qui aujourd'hui pourrait
vraiment bloquer la machine si on n'y
prend pas garde
donc tout ça pour dire que la dynamique
elle est engagée et donc la question que
vous posiez en introduction c'est
aurons-nous assez d'électricité pour
pour satisfaire toute cette nouvelle
demande
donc c'est la question sur lequel
beaucoup de mon travail sur lequel RTU
travaille avec une perspective de
publication de premiers résultats à
l'automne prochain en septembre prochain
sur le bilan prévisionnel
donc j'ai pas de scoop à vous donner
mais vraisemblablement on saura le faire
en énergie c'est en quantité de
mégawattheure produit sur l'année
si on poursuit dans la logique de jouer
sur tous les leviers à notre disposition
c'est-à-dire continuer à mobiliser
l'efficacité énergétique dans tous les
secteurs où c'est possible pour pour
réduire les besoins profiter des progrès
techniques
continuer à mobiliser des leviers de
sobriété pour que nos besoins
énergétiques soient strictement
proportionnées aux usages et peut-être
faire évoluer certains modes de vie
à cet horizon 2030 2035 il n'y aura pas
de nouveau nucléaires donc il faut
pouvoir
mobiliser optimiser la disponibilité du
parc existant et puis enfin évidemment
accélérer continuer à développer la
production d'énergie renouvelables qui
est des carbonée qui pourra alimenter
cette électrolyse
pour pour conclure je terminerai sur la
question de l'autre équilibre qui est
très important aux yeux de RTE qui est
celui de l'équilibre en puissance
attends c'est à dire bon il y a cet
équilibre en énergie en nombre de
mégawattheure produit sur l'année mais
combien même on aurait assez de
mégawattheure produit sur une année par
rapport à l'ensemble des besoins
insatisfaire encore faut-il que à chaque
instant à chaque heure de l'été de
l'hiver de du jour de la nuit on puisse
satisfaire les besoins
et là ça renvoie effectivement à la
question de mes électrolyseurs comment
vont-ils fonctionner
vont-ils fonctionner de manière quasi
permanente il y a effectivement cette
question d'amortissement de Décapex qui
est important ou vont-ils avoir une
certaine capacité de flexibilité une
capacité à s'effacer pour laisser la
place peut-être à d'autres besoins plus
prioritaires à certains moments de
l'année
pour être très concret aujourd'hui quand
on regarde les statistiques publiées en
temps réel par RTE la France exporte
plus de 10 gigawatts d'électricité donc
nous aurions aujourd'hui 10 gigawatts
disponibles essentiellement décarbonée
pour alimenter l'électrolyse
la même question le 12 décembre dernier
j'aurais dit les alimenter ne serait-ce
que 3 4 5 gigawatts d'électrolyseur
s'ils avaient le bon goût de s'arrêter
pendant une semaine ça ça nous
arrangerait bien donc cette question de
flexibilité elle est extrêmement
importante
RTE a mené un centre d'analyses alors on
pourra en reparler
je crois qu'il faut il faut affiner par
rapport à ce qui a dit Monsieur Faucheux
la durée optimale de fonctionnement elle
est effectivement très dépendante de
l'exposition de l'électrolyseur au prix
de marché
donc ce qu'on dit c'est que oui pour que
la filière se développe il faut
probablement immunisé en partie la
production d'hydrogène des carbonées de
la volatilité des prix de marché mais il
faut pas l'immuniser totalement parce
que sinon on aura des comportements qui
seront très coûteux pour la collectivité
il faut que lorsqu'il y a des pics de
prix qui traduisent une tension sur le
système électrique
ces électrolyseurs soit incités à à
s'effacer et dans des proportions qui
qui fassent que l'équilibre économique
global reste efficace
donc tout ça soulève encore d'autres
questions parce que quand on dit
flexibilité des électrolyseurs
sur le plan technique un appareil de
d'électrolyse dans une installation
d'électrolyse elle est capable de
moduler sa puissance on pense que les
c'est ce que les constructeurs nous
disent en tout cas on sait faire
la question c'est que cette élector dans
une chaîne de consommation de
l'hydrogène qui elle peut avoir du mal à
s'interrompre alors quand on pense à la
production de biocarburant ou de
carburant de synthèse on se dit bah à ce
moment là on peut sans doute interrompre
stocker le carburant et arrêter une
semaine c'est peut-être pas dramatique
quoi que enfin c'est bien que les flux
liés au carburant peuvent être aussi
extrêmement cruciaux
donc c'est tout l'ensemble de du système
hydrogène qu'il faut penser dès le
départ comme étant flexible pour qu'il
puisse s'insérer harmonieusement et un
coût maîtrisé dans le système électrique
qui a besoin de cette flexibilité
merci alors dans
présentation vous avez parlé que vous
aviez une demande de 12 Go watts
nouvelle en quelque sorte donc la
question mais vous avez bien dit tout à
l'heure qu'on en avait 10 de disponible
mais est-ce qu'on est en capacité de les
produire et dans cette demande est-ce
qu'il y a pas des projets qui vont
tomber de même et s'il y a pas de projet
qui tombe de même comment on régule on
organise une régulation de toutes ces de
tous ces projets
effectivement le chiffre est
impressionnant nous avons la conviction
que un centre de projets
ne vont pas aboutir c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a d'une part ensemble d'acteurs
nous ont fait des demandes aux quatre
coins de la France afin de repérer les
lieux où il pourrait se raccorder au
moindre coût sans contrainte
donc faut être déjà très clairement que
il y a il y a du il y a du surplus dans
un centre de zone industrielle nous
avons aussi des interrogations le
sentiment que plusieurs projets vivent
en fait la même demande d'hydrogène on
sait pas seulement que certains acteurs
industriels ont émis publiquement l'idée
qu'il pourrait recourir à l'hydrogène et
ont incité à ce que la concurrence se
développe en disant bah plus il y aura
d'acteurs mieux je serai à même de
choisir le meilleur cheval pour pour
fournir mon hydrogène
donc il y a cette concurrence qui joue
la question est comment est-ce que tout
ça sera régulé organisé alors je crois
que c'est en construction
le manque la Commission de la régulation
de l'énergie aura un rôle à jouer
aujourd'hui c'est probablement la
manière dont les aide et le soutien
public sera octroyé par l'État qui va
être en élément assez déterminant de
cette régulation
nous ce qu'on dit c'est qu'on voudrait
éviter que ce soit la capacité du réseau
qui soit cet élément de régulation le
réseau doit permettre d'alimenter des
volumes importants et on sait bien que
c'est quelque chose qui va se développer
dans la durée donc sont des
investissements qui font sens de toute
façon à long terme donc il faut trouver
d'autres manières de réguler que par la
rareté du réseau
merci je d'autres questions mais je vais
passer la parole à Dominique Lagarde
directeur de la stratégie enedis
monsieur Lagarde 15 minutes mais si il
vous faut plus
du moment qu'on a la lumière
merci la lumière arrive par le réseau de
distribution électrique publique donc
enedis c'est justement ce une des
entreprises mais donc la principale en
France qui exerce le service public de
distribution de l'électricité à 95% du
territoire de la métropole nous avons un
modèle d'activité pour mémoire qui est à
la fois nationale et local vous le savez
nous ne sommes pas propriétaire des
réseaux donc nous sommes en régime de
concession
[Musique]
les missions qui exerce enedis sont
définies sur le code de l'énergie
l'article l322,8 que vous connaissez
autant que moi et ils vise cette mission
elle est assurée on a avec un certain
nombre de résultats attendus et
notamment la disponibilité de la
cheminement de l'électricité pour
l'ensemble des consommateurs c'est un
point clé vous avez en tête que le temps
de coupure sur l'année c'est en moyenne
une heure ça veut dire que le réseau
assure une distribution de
99,99% du temps donc c'est un paramètre
dit comme ça qui est très important et
c'est aussi important pour les
électrolyseurs notamment vous l'avez
entendu la disponibilité du courant
électrique pour que toutes les machines
fonctionnent est un point qui est pas
seulement un point de logistique c'est
aussi un point économique absolument clé
pour le développement et des activités
concernées
peut-être encore un mot de présentation
d'enedis avant de donner quelques
éléments de positionnement généraux
en chiffres c'est 3600 trois pardon
36500 salariés un hélice donc c'est une
grosse équipe qui est répartie sur
l'ensemble des territoires et en termes
d'investissement c'est 4,4 milliards
d'euros en 2022 donc c'est aussi un
enjeu qui est considérable pour
l'économie des territoires c'est des
investissements qui portent sur le
patrimoine donc le réseau c'est des
investissements qui portent sur la
croissance du réseau c'est à dire
justement les usages dont on parle et
qui demande de l'électricité et puis
c'est aussi des investissements il faut
le signaler aussi en matière de système
d'information qui sont une des clés de
voûte de fonctionnement de l'ensemble
j'insiste là dessus parce que la
transition énergétique et les thèmes que
vous abordez la biogaz la biocarburant
l'hydrogène nécessite tous de
l'électricité et donc connecter enfin
les installations sont connectées soit
sur les autres transports soit sur les
autres distribution et les deux doivent
donc acheminer cette électricité au
moment où on se parle
on peut retenir que la consommation
française elle est soutirée sur le
réseau de distribution à hauteur des
trois quarts
et puis en matière d'industrie puisque
c'est un thème qui est quand même
aussi lié au thème du jour la
consommation du secteur industriel
français pour moitié soutirer sur le
réseau de distribution donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui à juste titre pour des
enjeux de décarponeations on parle des
gros sites et donc Jean-Philippe bien en
parler ils vont aussi et c'est un point
clé que c'est grossitent à basculer
mais en fait les petits sites vont aussi
petit à petit se décarboner donc c'est
important qu'on nous on s'intéresse à
ces enjeux de décarbonation de
l'industrie pour les petits sites mais
aussi sur les gros sites souvent il y a
des auxiliaires sur les auxiliaires
industriels sur les auxiliaires de vie
qui sont connectés sur les autres
distribution donc dans les enjeux qu'on
discute parfois ensemble et différents
endroits ici même aussi sur les
préparations de loi y compris pour la
loi sur l'industrie verte c'est
important que l'ensemble des réseaux
soit embarqués pour que en effet quand
les industriels font les investissements
pour se décarboner qu'ils aient pas de
problème de logistique entre guillemets
les réseaux soient aussi là pour pour
soutenir les besoins en électricité
bon voilà pour mémoire sur ce que fait
une edis et où on en est aujourd'hui
alors sur le thème du jour quel est le
positionnement général d'abord nous on
n'est pas producteur d'électricité on
n'est pas non plus on n'a pas des
process industriels autre que ceux de
l'électricité donc pour pour enedis il y
a pas chaque source d'écarbonée à sa
place dans l'avenir énergétique
on adhère aux diverses études qui sont
faites on a contribué au futur
énergétiques 2050 de RTE pour les
aspects de distribution et donc nous
voilà on a des études et on n'a pas de
parti pris pour ou contre tel ou tel
énergie décarbonée
il y en aura pour tout le monde le
besoin est elle que il y a pas de raison
que enedis disent bah il faut
l'électricité 100% électricité etc etc
on a largement dépassé tous ces enjeux
là et d'ailleurs dans chacun des
territoires et vous les connaissez dans
vos propres territoires il y a une
une combinaison il y a des atouts chez
les uns chez les autres qui font que
l'équilibre local sera un petit peu
différent de l'un à l'autre dans une
vision nationale qui fait l'objet de la
loi de programmation énergétique et
climat
la deuxième chose qu'on peut dire c'est
que les usages finaux ça a été dit par
mes camarades du jour là les usages
finaux ils sont complémentaires les
carburants synthétiques on les imagine
bien pour l'aérien pour le maritime les
l'hydrogène donc pour l'industrie et
dans une moindre mesure et j'entends qui
a un certain nombre de nuances sur la
question des transports lourds on voit
bien que les transports lourds ça va se
répartir sur beaucoup de choses et donc
c'est important aussi dans la dans les
politiques publiques que les priorités
qui sont reflétées un peu par celle-là
en tout cas la complémentarité soit bien
prise en compte dans les divers moyens
de soutenir ou pas le développement de
ces nouveaux
usages de l'électricité
ou de ces nouveaux biocarburants
le troisième point c'est que il y a un
temps industriel
qui est nécessaire au développement de
ces activités là
c'est pas qu'une question de
[Musique]
régulation c'est pas qu'une question de
soutien public il y a quand même un
temps de maturité à la fois sur les
process et je pense que les je suis pas
un spécialiste d'électrolyseur mais ceux
qui le sont peuvent témoigner d'un temps
de mise au point un temps de
perfectionnement de voilà des
performances tout simplement pour que ça
rend les choses plus faciles donc il y a
bien un temps de l'innovation
technologique tout se fait pas en un
jour et puis il y a un temps de modèle
d'activité c'est-à-dire de performance
économique donc ils ont Faucheux on a
donné un certain nombre d'éléments c'est
des choses que vous regardez plus que
nous à creuse mais c'est important de
partager ça parce qu'évidemment il y a
des moments où on parle beaucoup
beaucoup de l'hydrogène ou beaucoup des
biocarbures mais après il faut quand
même que les projets arrivent on les
connecte et puis que voilà qu'ils ont
qui trouvent leur vie économique donc
voilà pour pour nous c'est un point
important parce que ça veut dire que par
exemple l'hydrogène nous on le voit
arriver voilà
c'est pas c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
connecte une électrolyseur alors que
c'est tous les jours qu'on connecte un
panneau solaire tous les jours tous les
jours donc il y aura une différence de
il y a une pression on va dire sur les
réseaux qui est pas la même suivant les
différentes technologies le quatrième
point c'est que tous ces systèmes là
nécessite de l'électricité
petitement ou pas mon hydrogène on a vu
c'est un gros consommateur d'électricité
pour produire une tonne de hydrogène il
faut 52 mégawattheure enfin bon là donc
après on peut multiplier nombre de
tonnes et puis nombre de mégawattheure
vous avez cité les chiffres puissants
globaux enfin c'est des gros chiffres
l'hydrogène c'est pas c'est pas neutre
bien sûr pour des biocarburants il y a
moins besoin d'électricité au carburant
par construction il se fait à partir de
l'énergie du du
matériel de base de la bio
matériel on va dire et donc il y a
besoin d'électricité simplement pour
alimenter les communs donc c'est
différent c'est pas aussi lourd par
contre ça fait une connexion sur le
réseau de distribution à chaque fois
le cinquième point c'est que nous on est
on a pour mission de raccorder les
différents les différentes installations
et de le faire avec un une égalité de
traitement pour l'ensemble des
demandeurs
pas de rôle à dire mais on va prioriser
plutôt les panneaux solaires et puis
ensuite plutôt hydrogène et puis ensuite
plutôt les supermarchés et puis ensuite
plutôt les résidentiels et puis plutôt
non on a une système de file d'attente
et on est surveillé d'ailleurs pour
faire en sorte que on ne soit pas tenté
de raccorder plus l'un que l'autre voilà
donc 5 points clés qui me paraissent
certes des généralités mais qui sont
bonnes à
partager et qui montre que enedis
apporte bien sûr ce qu'il a apporté en
matière de réseau électrique mais ne
vient pas prendre parti sur le
développement de tel ou tel mission
un mot maintenant pour finir sur le ce
qui est raccordé au réseau aujourd'hui
ce qui est raccordé au réseau
aujourd'hui c'est en matière de
transition énergétique principalement
des panneaux solaires
des installations de production
éoliennes terrestres
et puis dans une beaucoup moindre mesure
d'autres systèmes de production des
carbonées ni hydrauliques la bioénergie
et la cogénération donc pour donner des
chiffres on a 14 GW de photomoltaïques
connectées au réseau de distribution
afin 2022 17 gigawatts d'éolien et 1,2
gigawatts de bio énergie c'est juste
pour fixer les idées sur ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
en connexion sur le réseau et la
croissance quand on se projette donc on
fait aussi un travail de projection
donc on combine avec RTE quand on est
sur des visions nationales mais on fait
un travail de projection au niveau des
territoires puisque le réseau de
distribution par construction il est
implanté dans chacun de vos territoires
et donc on fait une analyse locale
pour bien bien anticiper ce qui peut se
passer et c'est vrai que en priorise en
ce moment les gros volumes et donc quand
on se projette à 10 ans à 20 ans voire à
30 ans aujourd'hui ce qui domine c'est
la production des carbonées solaires et
éolienne et puis en termes d'usage
électrique les enjeux de véhicules
électriques et donc de points de charge
et aussi les enjeux de pompe à chaleur
voilà ce qui ce qui domine on va dire
dans les investissements qui sont
aujourd'hui constitués ou en tout cas
anticiper par enedis vous avez peut-être
en chiffres en tête le chiffre qui est
notre prévision d'investissement à 2040
de 96 milliards d'euros 2021 et ça c'est
une couverture de des investissements
qu'on anticipe à partir de la PPE
d'aujourd'hui et donc bien sûr on est à
l'affût de ce que ce qui sera adopté ce
que vous votreez sur la prochaine loi de
l'énergie du climat et donc ensuite la
PPE qui viendra parce que il y a des
paramètres qui vont augmenter et
d'autres qui vont peut-être bon en tout
cas être différents évolué et donc on a
besoin nous de
d'anticiper ces choses là donc pour nous
sur la période qui vient des 15
prochaines années la dynamique et
l'effort de raccordement et du coup
toute l'amélioration de la performance
Kennedy peut apporter sur ce domaine là
elle est tirée par l'éolien par le PV et
ce sera évidemment utile le jour où
prendront plus de place
l'hydrogène le biocarburant et les et
les carburants de synthèse et même
d'ailleurs la capture du CO2 etc parce
qu'en fait dans toutes les technologies
de décarbonation il y a beaucoup de
choses qui vont éclore donc donc voilà
je pense que dans les voilà 10-15
prochaines années la dominante qui fait
que enedis raccorde investi et du coup
améliore ses performances c'est porté
par
par la production des carbonées et les
usages d'électricité et que du coup on
sera une certaine manière au rendez-vous
pour raccorder un certain nombre
d'installations de de carburant de
synthèse et autres nouveaux nouvelles
technologies qui permettront d'avoir des
carbonation complète de notre activité
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire pour
introduire les échanges merci
trois trois questions il y en a une vous
l'avez abordé
quand on s'est rendu à Marseille et
qu'on a écouté la volonté du port de
Marseille de vouloir faire en sorte que
les l'ensemble des bateaux à quai ne
fonctionnent plus sur leur moteur sur
l'électricité
le chiffre qui nous a été donné c'était
5 gigoths si ma mémoire est bonne enfin
qu'il paraissent énorme mais c'est pose
derrière le problème des raccordements
et donc une première question c'est
comment accélérer les raccordements
qui dit développement
de nouveau
de nouveaux raccordement ça nécessite
aussi
d'évaluer les investissements
nécessaires si j'ai bien compris vous
avez parlé de 96 milliards j'ai pas
entendu l'année
d'euros 2021 et puis jusqu'à 2040
et est-ce que le réseau tout compte fait
s'adapte facilement
à la montée en puissance qui va être lié
aux voitures électriques je pense
notamment sur les les autoroutières et
comme hier il y a eu de grands retours
et demain il y aura un nouveau de grand
départ au même moment il y aura des
effets de pointe comment comment ces
effets de pointe peut être pris en
charge sur
la nécessité de ravitailler au même
moment les voitures perd si les poids
lourds sont aussi sur batterie je sais
pas trop mon domaine l'électricité si
vous voulez mais sans que ça va
nécessiter un certain nombre de
quantités et forcément des problèmes de
raccordement voilà ce que mes trois
petites questions
on est en plein dans l'actualité puisque
on raccorde à tour de bras et que pour
tenir un rythme
qui va de records en record on a
connecté 3,8 gigawatt de
production donc photovoltaïques et
éolienne terrestre cette année en 2022
pardon et 3,8 également en 2021
et en 2022 on a trois fois plus de
raccordement pour le même montant
pression sur les raccordements elle est
vigoureuse
les attentes sont extrêmement fortes en
termes de délai de raccordement donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour accéder à
raccordement
on fait plusieurs choses il y a un enjeu
de productivité interne d'améliorer
notre mode de travail et donc on a un
objectif de division par 2 des délais
dans raccordement qu'on avait fixé en
début 2020 pour une atteinte de résultat
en fin 2022 et donc le résultat il est
atteint
à l'exception de la de la famille des
raccordements de photovoltaïques où là
on a on a réduit de 33% mais on n'a pas
divisé par 2 donc c'est c'est une
première volet c'est la productivité de
nos de nos équipes de nos process etc
le deuxième volet c'est ce que vous avez
pu voter vous-même dans la loi
d'accélération des ENR c'est les enjeux
de permitting de process administratif
qui dépendent pas que des nudistes qui
sont en lien avec les administrations
locales ou nationales et ça c'est aussi
une aide à faire en sorte que les délais
globalement diminuent ensuite on a un
troisième volet qui est justement la
flexibilité c'est la discussion avec le
demandeur
en lisant écoutez vous demander telle
puissance et ça ça nécessite des travaux
qui sont importants donc durée etc mais
par contre
si vous demandez un peu moins de
puissance ou plus exactement si vous
acceptez d'être écrêté à certains
moments quelques heures dans l'année
alors vous pouvez avoir raccordement
plus rapidement donc c'est une
discussion qu'on a quasiment
systématiquement avec l'ensemble des
producteurs et c'est bien efficace
puisque ça permet en effet de trouver
des solutions qui réduisent les délais
et les coûts des raccordements et puis
enfin il y a c'est pas une idée
d'accélération mais c'est quand même une
idée d'anticipation le partage qu'on a
avec RTE d'ailleurs sur la logique qui
évoquait Jean-Philippe bonest c'est à
dire qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
comme investissement pour sur certaines
zones là où on est sûr de pas avoir de
regrets entre guillemets pour pouvoir
décider d'investissement quasiment
presque en amont même de disposer des
projets correspondants donc cette
mécanique là elle est en cours de
travail et je pense qu'elle est
prometteuse Jean-Philippe a mentionné
pour les sites industriels mais
évidemment c'est c'est pas limité aussi
industriel
après sur le port de Marseille et sur la
pointe est-ce qu'on aura possibilité de
tenir tout ça aujourd'hui c'est vrai
aujourd'hui on tient ses pointes les
pointes sont non négligeables sur les
postes sources il y a des pointes à 20
mégawatts en l'espace d'une demi-heure
enfin c'est des choses qui sont assez
rapides et donc qui sollicitent le
réseau donc aujourd'hui même le réseau
tient un certain nombre de de rampe ou
de ils ont d'appel de puissance assez
rapide donc on est évidemment confiant
sur les appels de puissance qu'on
pourrait voir au niveau local dans les
situations qu'on va trouver donc les
bandes de recherche sur autoroute etc
donc de ce point de vue là on est plutôt
confiant il y a pas de frein
de technologie il y a pas des choses à
inventer pour tenir toutes ces rampes de
consommation forte en matière
d'électricité
par contre c'est vrai qu'il y a un
besoin d'anticipation ne serait-ce que
pour équiper et ensuite pour mettre au
point les
logiques de flexibilité qui peuvent être
plus ou moins sophistiquées si on prend
les recharges de bornes de voitures
électriques non pas sur autoroute mais
dans des zones comme des centres
commerciaux ou dans des parkings
d'immeubles ou dans
dans des recharges à domicile c'est sûr
que vous avez un premier niveau
d'optimisation qui consiste à placer
votre charge là où ça vous coûte le
moins cher et si ça vous coûte le moins
cher c'est qu'il y a une demande
d'électricité qui est modeste et donc
vous allez la mettre naturellement là ne
serait-ce que pour gérer votre facture
si vous n'êtes pas trop intéressé par
une facture peut-être que vous allez
être intéressé par un contrat un peu
astucieux que un acteur du marché va
vous proposer pour dire finalement vous
vivez votre profil vu que dans votre
maison vous n'avez pas seulement un
véhicule mais vous avez aussi autre
chose on peut travailler ensemble et
trouver un contrat qui est adapté dans
ce cas là d'ailleurs moi je m'occuperai
de piloter moi-même votre fournisseur
avec le téléphone lui-même la
consommation et la finalement la
maîtrise de votre puissance appelée sur
sur le réseau donc il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui vont se développer
et qui nous donne plutôt confiance dans
le fait que ces pointes vont passer et
puis après voilà la pointe ultime est-ce
que voilà le 20 décembre quand tout le
monde où tout le monde en tout cas ceux
qui peuvent prennent l'autoroute et se
retrouvent avec une succession de
voitures électriques à la pointe je ne
sais pas si peut-être que un jour ou
deux il y aura quand même quelques
consignes de type de type Bison Futé sur
le thème voilà
Bison Futé
les les
ecordies attention là vous avez quand
même un petit risque de faire deux
heures d'attente comme d'ailleurs ça
peut arriver dans des véhicules non
électrique aujourd'hui
monsieur Yvan Faucheux oui j'ai rajouté
deux éléments dans le débat alors qu'ils
vont pas j'espère qu'ils vont pas trop
embrouillés on a beaucoup parlé de CO2
avoir aussi en tête que la mobilité
hydrogène c'est une mobilité qui est
adresse aussi des enjeux de pollution
locale un certain nombre d'alternatives
au transport que j'ai cités notamment le
biogaz ne font pas nous résolvent pas
signer ne permet pas de faire un zéro
émission
et donc je vais
surtout si vous regardez la mobilité
hydrogène la mobilité hydrogène dans les
zones affaiblissement ou dans les zones
qui présentent des congestions très
particulières en termes de pollution
locale je pense au Nox OPM aux
particules fines etc
l'hydrogène est devient une solution qui
valorise
un élément important qui est
qu'effectivement c'est une solution zéro
émission et avec un impact CO2 très
minime souvent puisque c'est des petits
trajets des petites distances mais avec
un impact local extrêmement fort et
notamment
pour les représentants des collectivités
de territoriales l'enjeu territoriale de
l'hydrogène parfois peut-être un enjeu
qui regarde aussi les questions de
pollution atmosphérique sujet qui n'est
pas souvent dans la table ce qui n'est
pas souvent abordé
s'il y avait des travaux sur le train
hydrogène justement
ça avait été particulièrement mis en
avant de façon assez paradoxale
pour des trains qui rentrent dans des
coeurs de ville
alors des trains qui rentrent dans des
coeurs de ville souvent la zone est
électrifiée pas forcément toujours il y
a des diesels qui a une époque chauffait
du côté de la gare du Nord et donc
effectivement on a on a cet élément à
voir en tête le deuxième élément c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une course
effrénée à ce que les réseaux de
transport d'hydrogène soit régulier
c'est la question de l'anticipation des
investissements qui m'y fait penser
mon cavéate enfin le caviat de la Creuse
c'est qu'attention réguler une activité
c'est finalement faire passer un risque
d'investissement de l'opérateur vers le
consommateur quand on régule un
investissement quand on régule un
opérateur
on fait confiance dans l'excellente
qualité du régulateur pour ne faire que
des investissements économiquement
intéressant
mais au-delà de ça le mécanisme profond
c'est que le consommateur infini se
retrouve quelque part des positaire du
risque d'investissement et donc
beaucoup d'expérience aujourd'hui sont
faites je pense notamment donc c'est
l'article 28 de la loi d'accélération
des ENR que vous avez voté récemment qui
qui permet de réarranger les files
d'attente qui fondamentalement dit
quelque part en contrepartie de se
réarrangement des files d'attentes et de
l'exclusion ou la dépériorisation d'un
certain nombre de porteurs de projets
j'accepte fondamentalement que tout ceci
rentre dans la régulation et donc
quelque part que le risque final euh
d'un investissement échoué soit bien sur
le consommateur et un consommateur au
sens large du terme autant je dirais là
sur des sujets sans regret on n'a pas de
regret puisque c'est une tautologie
autant sur des infrastructures sur
lesquelles on a encore énormément
d'interrogations c'est à dire notamment
les infrastructures qui vont peut-être
un jour relier ces grandes zones de
production et de consommation
d'hydrogène voire même des
infrastructures encore plus larges qui
vont aller encore plus loin pour aller
chercher l'hydrogène aux vertus des
carbonées voire vertes très très loin
il faut avoir en tête que cela demande
de régulation qui est fortement poussée
par la Commission européenne et par un
certain nombre d'États membres
elle a quand même comme conséquence de
retomber quelque part dans la facture du
consommateur et là dessus la creux est
extrêmement prudente elle est prudente
d'une part parce que parce que augmenter
la facture du consommateur c'est jamais
un geste tout à fait naturel et puis
surtout prudent parce que le modèle
économique d'un certain nombre de
projets d'hydrogène notamment s'il faut
faire des électrolyseurs qui s'échangent
de l'hydrogène entre Dunkerque et
Marseille je ne sais pas quel est le
modèle économiques sous-jacents et donc
commencer à faire porter le risque
d'investissement sur un modèle
économique qu'on ne connaît pas à un
consommateur dont on sait que lui il
aura pas le choix
c'est une équation sur laquelle il est
toujours très compliqué de s'engager
avec un degré d'assurance
en l'absence ce que je disais tout à
l'heure de tout business plan de tout
modèle économique à stabiliser sur ces
applications là
voilà c'était les deux qui avaient hâte
que je voulais faire un plutôt pour
l'hydrogène et puis un plutôt contre
l'hydrogène vous remarquerez pour une
fois la creux et mesure
merci je me retourne vers mes collègues
pas de question
simplement puisque vous faites de la
prospective dans vos travaux quelle est
la place des des bio-carburants et au
niveau de l'usage de l'hydrogène est-ce
que il y a une hiérarchisation qui est
pensée ou pas voilà
alors quelle est la place des
biocarburants ou nous on voit que les
biocarbures essentiellement par
l'utilisation de l'électricité pour
faire des biocarburants donc
effectivement on est plutôt sur des
ordres de grandeur qui reste très
limitées je crois que j'ai 11 terawater
en tête donc ça reste quand même
extrêmement limité au final
difficile de se prononcer
c'est-à-dire ce que les biocarburants
est-ce que les carburants de synthèse
seront limités au transport aérien ou
pas
ça je préfère faire un déclinatoire de
compétences et après sur les usages de
l'hydrogène oui très clairement on a une
priorisation priorisation sur les sites
industriels et les usages industriels
non substituables ou non susceptibles
d'avoir une concurrence ensuite
transport lourd pour lequel l'hydrogène
devient une alternative par rapport au
stockage électrochimique compte tenu
soit de l'autonomie soit des temps de
recharge soit de contraintes logistique
liés à aux transports collectif ou à des
transports qui doivent tourner de façon
très très régulière puisque l'hydrogène
a également cette autre avantage de
pouvoir être chargé très rapidement
contrairement à la batterie
électrochimique qui présente encore des
difficultés en termes de temps de
recharge
et puis comme l'avait rappelé monsieur
bonnet l'utilisation de l'hydrogène pour
équilibrer le réseau ou pour utiliser de
l'énergie pas chère ou pour faire des
des
comment dire des passerelles temporelles
de stockage entre l'été et l'hiver
c'est un usage qui n'est pas forcément
exclu mais en tout cas qui n'appelle pas
aujourd'hui d'action régulatoire à court
et moyen terme
oui merci peut-être sur ce sujet
simplement rappeler pour que ce soit
bien compris
dans les questions d'accès au réseau
c'est à dire de réservation de capacité
pour pouvoir être alimenté aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas dans le cadre de
réglementation ou de régulation de
possibilités d'organiser une priorité la
règle qui prévaut c'est premier arrivé
premier servi sont des règles qui qui
datent de l'ouverture à la concurrence
du marché qui avait vocation à ouvrir
largement de ne pas avoir de priorité
pour les acteurs déjà installés et qui
ont fonctionné dans un contexte où
depuis 20 ans on avait quand même une
certaine stabilité de la consommation
voir une décroissance et assez peu de
nouvelles implantations donc aujourd'hui
le texte vous avez voté
donne des premiers outils à l'état mais
après consultation de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie pour pouvoir
éventuellement dans certains cas très
précis réorganiser cette priorité parce
que ce qu'on constate de plus en plus
c'est qu'il y a concurrence pour l'accès
à la capacité du réseau de différents
usages dans le cas que vous citiez du
port de Marseille l'alimentation des
navires raqués il y a aujourd'hui
clairement une concurrence qui s'exerce
sur Genesis entre eux cet usage là et
puis des besoins des datacenters par
exemple qui sont nombreux voire
s'installer sur Marseille qui doit
réguler tout ça arbitrer tout ça ce qui
est souhaitable c'est qu'à terme il y a
cette capacité pour tout le monde mais
il y a une problématique de dans le
temps il faut quand même investir il
faut créer ces ouvrages et donc qui est
le premier arrivé qui doit attendre un
peu son tour c'est aussi une question
qui se pose pour l'hydrogène et c'est
bien c'est bien l'objet des dispositions
de pouvoir permettre aux autorités
compétentes et après mieux réflexion de
pouvoir organiser cet ordre d'arrivée je
vous en prie je rajouterais juste
rapidement que le l'article 27 de la loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables ne vise pas que
l'hydrogène aussi
tous les projets de d'efficacité
énergétique de décarbonation alors il y
a un mot qui va être très compliqué à
factualiser qui sont de décarbonation
significative
tout est dans le significatif évidemment
mais effectivement cette concurrence
n'est pas
elle avait rappelé dans les 12 gigawatts
de demandes qui arrivent sur les 10
sites prioritaires oui trois quarts
doivent être de l'hydrogène un quart ne
sont pas de l'hydrogène un quart sont
d'autres technologies plus voilà donc
effectivement le
y compris même si l'hydrogène peut ne
pas avoir d'alternative pour la
décarbonation d'un certain nombre de
process en revanche quand on regarde
localement les bassins industriels
l'hydrogène se retrouve pour le coup en
concurrence avec d'autres projets de
décarbonation et d'efficacité
énergétique monsieur Lagarde peut-être
qu'on peut dire derrière tout ce qu'on
dit là il y a donc une bonne nouvelle
qui est la croissance des
infrastructures dont on a besoin et je
présente comme une bonne nouvelle parce
que ça veut quand même dire des
investissements donc du travail et donc
des ressources humaines et donc des
développements finalement de compétences
et donc des emplois et je le dis parce
que évidemment si au moment où on se
parle on on a besoin de tout d'un coup
dix mille personnes dans la filière ça
va être compliqué mais si on sait que on
en a pour deux ans cinq ans 10 ans 15
ans alors on a une vraie perspective qui
s'ouvre qui est vrai pour l'ensemble des
des lieux de formation que ce soit des
reconversions que ce soit des lycées des
bacs pro etc donc c'est voilà je le dis
parce que c'est un des sujets qu'on
prend à bras le corps avec une école des
réseaux électriques qui vise avec
l'ensemble de la filière des réseaux
électriques à faire en sorte que on
recense les besoins dans la durée et
surtout qu'on y mette des dispositions
pour y répondre et aujourd'hui juste
pour fixer les idées il y a
8600 personnes qui sont formées à
l'électricité à partir de bac pro ou de
BTS et en fait ces gens là alimentent
l'ensemble des activités électriques
aujourd'hui du pays et bien les besoins
de la filière réseau électrique
c'est-à-dire des entreprises de travaux
qui bossent pour nous-mêmes représentent
ce montant là donc en fait on serait
si on laisse les choses telles qu'elles
on finirait par ne pas avoir assez de
moyens humains le nous est en très
collectif puisque c'est l'ensemble des
entreprises donc ça c'est un vrai
challenge mais c'est un truc qui est un
challenge on va dire humain positif qui
entraîne l'ensemble du pays parce que
tous les responsables vous savez comme
moi les responsables des lycées c'est
pas les mêmes que les responsables du
collège c'est pas les mêmes etc donc
tout ce monde là doit travailler
ensemble là-dessus donc peut-être je
sais pas si c'est une note de conclusion
en tout cas c'était un point que je
voulais partager avec vous parce que il
est d'une nature un tout petit peu
différente
des vues comment dirais-je
optimiste en même temps
sans vouloir être pessimiste pour
développer votre réseau vous avez besoin
de matières premières
de cuivre voilà et qui a un moment donné
le cuivre et d'aluminium aujourd'hui on
utilise pas mal d'aluminium je suis sans
doute pour les raisons que vous avez pas
encore sur un autre débat à ma
connaissance la terre aux dimensions
finies et tout ce qu'on a sur terre
c'est du stockage voilà et ce qui est
pas stocké c'est ce qu'il peut se
développer grâce au soleil
mais c'est un autre débat je voudrais
simplement vous demander avant de
quitter on revient la l'Académie des
technologies elle vient de sortir un
avis
publié un avis très critique sur la
politique européenne disons qu'on pourra
pas atteindre les deux objectifs qui
sont fixés ce qu'on peut avoir votre
point de vue
difficile de critiquer un régulateur a
beaucoup difficultés à critiquer un
gouvernement puisque comme je le disais
bien évidemment par séparation
de même que je domaine que j'aurais
beaucoup de mal avec un gouvernement qui
critique un régulateur
néanmoins peut-être et au cas de
l'hydrogène une question alors déjà le
travail de la commission est pas évident
parce qu'il y a quand même à peu près 7
règlements et directives qui sont
impactés par l'hydrogène y compris la
directive sur la taxation des produits
énergétiques qui ne faut pas oublier
puisque c'est quand même une directive
non neutre en terme de en termes
d'efficacité carbone des différents
vecteurs
en revanche un élément qui pour nous est
toujours très interrogatif c'est cette
confusion vers des carbonée
alors qui renvoie au cas français plutôt
sur la question du nucléaire et bien
évidemment mais quelque part on mélange
effectivement le développement des
énergies des carbonées
passera naturellement par le
développement des énergies renouvelables
on a un besoin tellement immense qu'on
n'arrivera pas tout faire et donc il y a
pas de choix à faire entre le nucléaire
versus le renouvelable en revanche faire
un choix technologique immédiat sur un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui soit
de nature réglementaires ou de
dispositifs de soutien par rapport au
l'hydrogène qui embarque finalement un
choix sous-jacent sur la mode sur le
mode de décarbonation est très étonnant
et pour le coup autant que régulateur et
je crois que ça rejoint assez fortement
un certain nombre de positions du
gouvernement français
c'est de dire laisser là-dessus fixer un
objectif de décarbonation mais laisser
les différents états avoir le choix des
moyens qu'ils entendent mettre au
service de cette décarbonation et au cas
de l'hydrogène le débat est vraiment
extrêmement cristallisé en raid 2 je
sais pas si vous avez vu le mélodrame de
la semaine dernière le débat se
cristallise à énormément dessus si je
devais avoir un constat d'étonnement
plus qu'une critique sur la politique
européenne c'est finalement d'avoir dans
son raisonnement
une bifurcation immédiate des
carbonation égale renouvelables
et au cas d'hydrogène et les patates
je vous remercie de nous avoir consacré
de votre temps de vous expliquer vous
éclairages et puis j'ai bien compris que
pour avoir la lumière chez moi il faut
la complémentarité d'une chaîne
d'entreprise et que dans une chaîne la
force de la chaîne c'est le maillon le
plus faible donc je souhaite que les uns
et les autres vous renforciers merci
beaucoup